bonsoir à vous bonsoir à vous franc
poireaux vous êtes le vice-président du
radio-club de 50 ans en Yvelines on
quitte donc cette actualité plutôt
difficile du jour on va se projeter sur
un rendez-vous et les premiers 2 juin
une expédition radio au sommet de la
colline des longs courts ça fait un peu
aventurier comme ça ça va consister en
quoi c'est un petit peu aventurier c'est
pour nous la troisième partie du
championnat de France radioamateur donc
au sommet de la colline d'Élancourt quel
point le plus haut de l'Île-de-France à
231 mètres d'altitude donc une de 10
entre 10 et 20 radio amateurs de
l'association vont se réunir et se
relever tout le long du week-end pour
contacter un maximum de stations
radioamateur en France et à l'étranger
sur des bandes de fréquences qui sont
dites hyper fréquents c'était fréquences
qui sont pour les plus basses un petit
peu au dessus des fréquences qu'on
utilise en radio Diffusion FM et pour
les plus hautes qui sont au dessus des
fréquences utilisées par les satellites
merci c'est une compétition le but de
cette épreuve c'est de faire intervenir
une dizaine de radios amateurs justement
de l'association d'établir un maximum de
contacts avec des stations
comment ça se passe concrètement alors
le championnat de France c'est ça se
prépare c'est vrai que depuis trois ans
on demande l'autorisation d'accéder à la
colline pour pouvoir avoir un petit
point privilégié qui puisse augmenter un
petit peu notre capacité à contacter le
maximum de gens mais pour nous le
championnat en lui-même c'est pas
vraiment la finalité la finalité c'est
un petit peu d'avoir Federer tout autour
d'un projet en fait tous les membres de
l'association ça combien ça sera entre
10 et 20 mais c'est une année c'est un
projet un petit peu d'une année puisque
un peu plus de 70% des équipements qu'on
va déployer là haut c'est des
équipements qui sont conçus réalisés par
les membres de l'association et donc ça
soit les antennes les mains les
émetteurs récepteurs une bonne partie en
fait des équipements sont conçus dans
dans l'association et on va pouvoir un
petit peu tester voir un petit peu
comment ça marche grâce à ce rendez-vous
justement vous concevez tout ça avant
donc ces journées de premier 2 juin vous
concevez vous testez vous améliorer
aussi comment se passe la préparation
c'est ça donc tous les ans en fait on
fait un petit débriefing de ce tout
s'est bien passé la troisième fois c'est
la troisième fois qu'on sera sur ce
rendez-vous et donc les deux premières
les deux premières fois on a terminé
vice champion de France donc c'est vrai
que il manque pas grand chose pour
accéder à la première marche et donc
cette année encore on a réalisé des
quelques antennes supplémentaires des
moyens de
commutation d'une antenne à l'autre de
communication d'une bande de fréquence
sur une autre bande de fréquence tout un
schéma un petit peu stratégique
technique dans la réalisation des
équipements d'organisation de logistique
parce que c'est plus de 17 antennes plus
de 8 émetteurs récepteurs qui vont être
déployés la colline il n'y a pas
d'énergie donc faut déployer des moyens
d'énergie le radioamateur aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un qui vit avec internet
avec l'informatique donc il y aura des
moyens internet informatique qui vont
être déployés là-haut qu'est-ce qui fait
la différence même entre les clubs parce
que vous nous dites vous terminez à
chaque fois aux portes de ce titre de
cette première place pourquoi certains y
arrivent ben qu'est-ce qu'il fait la
différence c'est un petit peu
l'expérience nous ça fait trois ans donc
si on pouvait gagner du premier coup ça
sera un petit peu trop facile et
donc je pense qu'il y a encore il
beaucoup de radios club comme nous qui
ont une bonne expérience et puis qui
participent aussi la motivation du club
c'est d'essayer d'atteindre cette
prendre de rivaliser avec cette première
marche alors ce qu'on vous souhaite
aussi c'est d'avoir une météo favorable
là c'est l'imagine que c'est compliqué
sinon donc voilà donc si elle est pas
favorable on espère qu'elle sera pas
favorable pour tout le monde mais donc
aujourd'hui on part avec un objectif qui
est
météo qui sera clémente après on
s'adaptera en fonction des éléments
c'est une compétition il y a une
première place en jeu même si vous nous
avez dit le but c'est aussi de fédérer
toutes les énergies du club sur ce
projet commun et puis il y a aussi
l'ambition de démontrer que que ce type
par exemple d'expédition préfigure de ce
que pourrait être une intervention en
cas d'urgence par exemple voilà tout à
fait donc certains radios amateurs se
regroupent au travers de de
d'associations départementales des
radios amateurs au service de la
sécurité civile c'est-à-dire que
bénévalement certains radiateurs se
regroupent et se mettent au service de
la préfecture pour pouvoir en cas de
catastrophe naturelle de plan Orsec par
exemple mettre à la disposition de la
préfecture des moyens de transmission
qui pourraient déployer
et le projet par exemple de liaison avec
ce cette station internationale spatiale
vous pourriez le relancer oui on
pourrait le relancer alors on est sur
d'autres projets maintenant notamment
avec l'IUT de Ville d'Avray peut-être
plus sur des communications lunaires
merci à vous je rappelle que votre
sommet de la colline d'Élancourt pour
cette compétition de radioamateur
premier et deux jeunes ouvrons bien
évidemment vous rendre visite le
reportage sera suivi sur notre antenne
je rappelle que vous êtes le
vice-président ce sera dit au club
amateur à 50 ans en Yvelines merci à
vous